all right so Disney have screwed up and
this downfall has been honestly slow and
agonizing to watch I've been completely
checked out of pretty much every single
Disney plus Marvel series since Loki
wrapped up and saved for maybe one or
two Phase 4 Films I have not had a good
time checking them out then I remembered
there was still one story that wasn't
resolved Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
was waiting for me I decided to allow
this to be my farewell to the franchise
that admittedly gave me some terrific
films and characters I sat myself down
into the theater I watched this finale
to guns Trilogy and man I cried like
four separate times for different
reasons this in my opinion is easily one
of the best films visually and
scripturally that Marvel has produced
not just since endgame but maybe overall
and in my opinion I think the Guardians
Trilogy is more impressive than any
other MCU Trilogy to date if you haven't
seen it you should James Gunn's a genius
when it comes to character writing
keeping things simple and delivering a
cohesive story